[Music]
and sexy takeover dudes what was that
funny submitted by love from England yo
England fly us out their room is my city
love you too is it I love you in your
ancestor city all your asses I don't
know any of those she's been watching
the Shane Dawson stuff oh he's doing
that documentary on him right now
stop watching YouTube man I don't know
[ __ ] yo Shane is killing it though he's
killing with those are YouTube
documentaries man they're very
interesting do man they're so serious
did a cruise ship refunded passengers
after a large group turned the ship into
their personal party boat oh [ __ ] they
got hijacked by a party that's kind of
dope and then they got they all got to
refine the people that weren't in the
party that's a nice service maybe even
some of the ones that were in the party
but they got out yeah they're like hey
what's up with this [ __ ] party bunch
of party poopers I don't understand okay
so there was this cruise a Royal
Caribbean International cruise where
there were about like 3,000 passengers
but I already feel miserable and there
was about 1300 workers from this Indian
company who went on board for a
conference 1,300 employees been amazing
they just shut down their business and
[ __ ] damn it was definitely a call
center yeah that's crazy I was gonna say
rug shop oh my god for you isn't it
wasn't like a tobacco company after like
I read that that's racist
it's the tobacco company yeah so then
that was pretty racist joke about you I
know it's such a stereotypical Indian
job they're trying to get away from that
image job is it oh is it Native American
is that what it's about
do you think American spirits and shapes
you don't think I smoke cigarettes in
India since we're going races we want to
go there huh let's go there huh okay no
like the country of India Oh was that a
proper okay mister okay anyway so these
all these workers they so anyway the
boat left from Sydney and it was a
sickening it was about a three-day
cruise and they just they had brought
these women dressed as Playboy Bunnies
onto the boat oh you have a geek
roulette shows and they brought him onto
the behind he brought their own into
entertainment they did them all tickets
right I think they did they were a part
of the 1300s yeah I think they were
ingenuity dude even to the [ __ ] end
is [ __ ] yeah about how do you not a
party [ __ ] you like that Bollywood [ __ ]
like they have to have 1500 of them if
they're all gonna dance together that's
why there's so there's probably like
five employees and twelve hundred and
ninety-five performers they know how to
party I gotta go to an Indian party
Yogi's are [ __ ] crazy I love how they
just set it all up like on their own too
and they have their own entertainment
yeah where they brought their own
catering and all this year that's
amazing
so are they saying that the families on
that cruise they were forced to take
refuge inside their cabins like they
could because they took over every inch
of it were they like there's just too
much titties they don't like to party
well I mean they're kids I'd be pissed
it's a family yeah yeah there's like
family and then they're also really
angry because the these people these
workers they were also like recording
these girls that were on the trip with
their family or whatever it was like a
girl that were not part of their group
it would film them with their phones but
they treated it like it's their own like
bachelor a [ __ ] cake yeah he brought
their own beads and [ __ ] come on
we're throwing him at fourteen-year-olds
Indian Mardi Gras yeah you know you guys
were laughing about them catering there
they did they brought crates of and
crates of their own food Ponce's well
I'm down because they probably got like
garlic good food paneer and the favorite
like all the families there they're just
being that was ruined why is it like
beer I'm just assuming that it's it was
like like male [ __ ] straight up like
douchebaggery yes it was like 1300 like
Indian or like 200 Indian dudes with
like 1100 like sex workers or some [ __ ]
well they were saying people on that
boat they were saying that it was just a
one gigantic like bachelor party like
they were just going crazy and they took
over like the whole like every bar every
pool like they were just everywhere
that's tight I wish I was there that's
whole [ __ ] hate community pools like
that like on cruise ships it's like the
most disgusting thing ever
there are so much dick [ __ ] and old
people in there is disgusting it is a
[ __ ] bacterial stew and no one no one
obeys the role of life you're supposed
to rinse for exactly
no one does I don't know why you know
what I liked about it is when the boat
was rocking yeah yeah and it kept
hitting these kids but the little boy
was drowning yeah well if you put it
that way it was kind of sad but what we
saw was pretty funny cuz we dropped for
like a couple seconds remember as a
little boy tossed around he was so funny
literally no he was a jockey but he kept
getting hit with the water like the
water would come in this kid would be
like trapped but then you would get out
but he was crying but it was like it
wasn't in danger in the grandpa kept
trying to like get up get the kid but
that grandpa would get would you like
push them the other way - oh my god try
to get him that's like the ocean dude
that cruise boat was hard to play
basketball we were on the roof
can't play basketball and then we would
try to shoot and then it would rock and
in the [ __ ] Hall hoop would just move
just go like this fellas parties I suck
so bad actually help me going on I'm so
good here
it's like that carnival game with like
when you play basketball yeah and it
comes back with dad you out yeah it's
okay she's not good at many things in
life like give her that emotions yeah
[ __ ] yeah I didn't I was sick a lot yeah
I don't get motion sickness a good
Mexican exactly I don't get motion
sickness enough swearing like it really
affects me but it does not feel like
land so I know there's a clear
difference we're like I don't get like
super woozy but there's like a little
base layer of life this isn't that
comfortable I'm like completely fine I
just I get motion sick let's say if it's
moving like that right yeah and then I'm
trying to read something oh yeah this is
stationary but everything is good then I
guess you couldn't go on your phone and
stuff while you're in the cruise will we
have no reception anyways so I didn't
but then if I try it with the moments I
was trying to get like Wi-Fi or some
[ __ ] I got a little dizzy I'm like oh
don't look at that and then I was fine
or if I preoccupy myself with another
sense then it helps out you know we're
into Italian restaurant oh you feel good
bit like this and the waiters I would
like to order and then I'm like reading
the menu [ __ ] get when the food came
out I put that one bite of my mouth off
mm-hmm and it takes over so I made my
tongue don't get much sicker
yeah doesn't do anything to me to drink
that [ __ ] sucks
so you don't even feel 1% of that
[ __ ] sucks that's great no it sucks
for you guys I'm just like like damn it
does suck do you oh I felt sure rat
yeah the bone is fine I will go I will
go like on boats and and as a kid and
stuff and I would just want to rock it
hard and in like my dad hated that [ __ ]
but that's not the hard motion it's
almost like that it's like the confident
wave
equilibrium and like if it was harder
like a jet ski like I wouldn't get
motion sickness from that but it's like
that slow some of it is relaxing cuz it
feels like like like I'm being rocked Oh
you guys are we already filled I feel
dizzy right now can we change the
subject
let's talk about some land stories yeah
you guys know that feeling where do you
like a tree right oh yeah guys ever get
buried in the sand he just can't move
yeah cuz I woke up dizzy as luck today
II - and they have they don't sound like
yeah that's to the bone I've been
drinking a lot lately oh I don't know
level water you know like back yeah
alcohol you drink a lot when I was in
Cape Town and for some reason I just
drinking a lot more man I don't know why
because you're meeting up with old
friends or Wendy are you drinking by
yourself no it's definitely a social
thing you don't mean so because I'm
going out a little I'm trying to be a
little more social oh that's funny
you've never invited you know you drink
anyone I dream no you drink I dream you
barely drink did I mean but a dream
every time I try to get you drink since
we've had an amazing time a couple times
but that geo has died you know more fun
I'm kidding I'm kidding I drank and I
[ __ ] up I sort of fallen asleep during
the blue man like I just wanted a drink
out with Casey Kay's come on you had a
drink on the iPhone just woke up with
blue paint on you so the show is dope
that's not knocking the [ __ ] you fall
asleep early again in Vegas we are there
yeah we're guys are beat because that
same day we walk like three million
miles
oh yeah we're like should we get a taxi
but now let's just walk it and then it
was only said two miles on the map but
two miles in Vegas is like up the
escalator around the hotel over there so
it's like two miles isn't regular it's
not linear yeah it's a lot of like
[ __ ] loop-de-loop to this hotel to
that hotel
oh I know why it was two miles cuz you
were on the car setting you should have
done the wall just walk sitting but it's
illustrative two miles all right yeah it
doesn't go up and this and like that it
was so funny cuz in the middle of the
show I was sitting next to geo Casey
over here and then Bart was over there
and geo was like [ __ ] it Bart and I look
over you like this
[ __ ] like this if I drink I can I still
like my holiday school other clubs with
the homies I could like knock out on a
sub woofer yeah
alcohol puts me the [ __ ] out actually
dad I think a tranquilizer ask me it's
like my cool yeah it's so strong for me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]